yeah I think that you know they're you
know for thousands of years people have
made the observation that there's
certain kinds of extreme depressive
states that seem to be more likely to
produce philosophers people in the arts
unusually brilliant scientists and
modern studies a lot of monitors have
borne that out that there is a
disproportionate rate of mood disorders
of depression and bipolar disorder in
highly creative groups in the arts
sciences and so forth I think that
that's a real phenomenon I think that
the changes that go on in the brain when
people are mildly manic the experiences
of extreme states the kind of
experiences that people then go on to
write and create about all those things
you know I think are reasonably well
documented its controversial but it's
you know actually the studies are almost
all in the same direction there's that
doesn't get away from the fact that
these people a lot of these people who
are highly creative also had very
miserable lives and I try and point this
out when people start romanticizing
mental illness is that you know Byron
and Van Gogh you know wanted to be
treated Byron traveled with doctors Van
Gogh admitted himself finally to a
hospital the they weren't in pain and
suffering so it's not a romantic life it
may look romantic from the outside but
if you read their letters and their
correspondence with friends you know
it's not anything wonderful and many of
them died young by suicide and the rate
of suicide is also way
disproportionately high in in these
highly creative groups and it's the last
thing you want is people dying young on
dying prematurely in any event so I
don't think it has to be a choice
between being creative and being on
medication in this day and age we've got
a lot of wide variety of medications and
psychotherapy and people kept at much
lower doses than they used to be I mean
used to be in the early days of lithium
people were really tanked up on lithium
so that you know I think it really did
have an effect